matt james's bachelor journey is over
but there's a new lead on the horizon
actually two of them should we tell
bachelor nation
on monday night emmanuel acho took over
hosting the bachelor after the final
rose and was joined by contestants katie
thurston
and michelle young but there's no use in
drawing it out any longer because a
decision
has been made should we tell bachelor
nation
where the bachelorette that's right two
separate seasons
two separate women two separate journeys
hopefully ending up
and two separate engagements this will
be the first time in bachelor history
that the franchise will be airing two
back-to-back seasons of the bachelorette
katie will begin her journey on season
17 of the show slated to air in the
summer
while michelle will take the lead for
season 18 airing this fall on abc
i mean i'm ready to find love and not
just like
the temporary kind i'm talking forever
my husband
and i'm in a place in my life where i
feel like i'm the best version of me
when you can set down all these outside
distractions and really
dive in i think you can learn a lot
about somebody
i'm just excited i'm ready to get
started emanuel filled in for chris
harrison who was taking a temporary lead
from the show
after this february interview well
rachel
is it a good look in 2018 or is it not a
good look in 2021
because there's a big difference ever
because you're she's celebrating the old
south she's so if i went to that party
what would i represent at that party
chris appeared to defend current
bachelor winner rachel kirknell in that
interview who came under fire for past
racially insensitive actions
including attending an old south
plantation themed party
while in college in 2018. please stop
saying that i did nothing wrong that's
not true chris later issued an apology
on good morning america
i stand against all forms of racism and
i am
deeply sorry i'm sorry to rachel lindsay
and i'm sorry to the black community
last week it was announced chris will
not be hosting the next season of the
bachelorette and that former leads tasha
adams and caitlyn bristow will be
taking his place the statement read
quote as we continue the dialogue of
achieving greater equity and inclusion
within the bachelor franchise we are
dedicated to improving the bipoc
representation of our crew including
among the executive producer ranks
you